Let's look at the answer to our DRAM
technology quiz which was asking us,
why not use a normal transistor and
a capacitor when making DRAM?
Is it because trench
cell is easier to make?
This is not true.
The trench cell is not easier to make.
It requires us to bury
something into the silicon.
So this one is actually incorrect.
Trench cells are more difficult to
make than capacitors, technologically.
Trench cell is more reliable.
This is also not true.
Trench cell let's us make
cheaper DRAM chips.
It looks like trench cells
are more difficult to make, so
the chips will be more expensive.
But remember that the cost
of a chip grows quickly
when the area is increased and decreases
quickly when the area is decreased.
The trench cell occupies a lot less
area on the chip than the transistor and
the capacitor normally would.
So, if we want to build a chip that has
the same number of bit with the trench
cell, or this way, the trench
cell results in much smaller and
thus way, way less expensive chips.
So this really is the correct answer.